hey Jen so good to see you I love that  you never make any effort at all what  are you doing here this is my friend's  very real wedding you can't pull your  crap here oh okay well I see the Chit  Chat is over the answer to your  extremely rude question is that I happen  to be dating a friend of the groom and  he invited me  Titania hey girl hey you made it you're  so busy though you have like 5 000  businesses  what no no she has weasled her way into  this wedding to mess with me that is so  obvious why does nobody else see that  okay you're being very loud Jen I hear  you again I do  but you sound insane right now like  titanium wouldn't just show up to my  wedding you know try and kill you or  something I don't know I'm literally  just here to celebrate the love of Lulu  and her groom that's all okay